ehi ciao
[Musica]
ma lei
se vivo di musica e sono qui stasera a
parlarvene e perché la musica mi ha
fatto piangere tante volte quando ero un
bambino anche se non capivo se erano
lacrime di gioia lacrime di malinconia
di dolore e di estrema felicità
probabilmente era stupore per quello che
stavo scoprendo di me e del mondo sono
stato quindi un fruitore di musica
curioso e famelico nell'infanzia
ho giocato sempre accompagnato dal mio
mangiadischi e quando avevo il salotto
libero metteva sul piatto un disco di
colonne sonore western di moriconi
mentre io trucidano senza pietà dei
cowboy immaginari elementari le stangate
dandomi la carica rock and roll i stones
e poi e poi mi sono imbattuto nel modo
di suonare la batteria di stewart
copeland batterista dei police e
nonostante le mie insistenze una
batteria in casa mia non c'è mai entrata
a 13 anni ho rischiato invece di
lasciarci le venne preso la meningite in
un torneo di pallamano internazionale a
teramo e quindi ho avuto una
convalescenza di tre mesi d estate e in
cui non potevo fare niente di tutto ciò
che facevano i miei amici quindi non
potevo fare il bagno non potevo prendere
il sole e anche quando uscivo dopo il
tramonto non potevo giocare a pallone
perché non potevo sudare
avevo un amico più grande che aveva una
chitarra il permesso un'aula in maniera
fantastica conosceva tutte le canzoni
che ti piacevano per cui iniziai da lui
inizia a imparare la chitarra e molti
anni dopo quando ero già un chitarrista
professionista
io da solo e una casa e sotto e uno
studio di registrazione professionale
non cantavamo ancora perché abbiamo
c'era abbastanza così che avevo un
problema di sette deviato ed i turbinati
ipertrofici mentre ero in ospedale per 3
4 giorni per risolvere questo problema
i ladri entrarono in casa mia e
svaligiarono tutto casa e in studio di
registrazione
li lasceranno soli vestiti quello che mi
dissi e che avevo perso tutto ma leo
riacquistato la mia voce finalmente è
inoltre l'ossigeno che per la prima
volta schizzava al cervello velocemente
gli dava una freschezza inedita per cui
andare a dublino con una chitarra
prestata e una manciata di canzoni e
dagli inizi al mio percorso
chi mi porta a quello che sono oggi
quindi un cantautore continua a essere
un chitarrista un produttore musicale è
un compositore lavoro molto con il
teatro scrivo colonne sonore
e poi mi piace invece portare avanti dei
dei format dei degli eventi basati
sull'incontro di artisti diversi con
ilaria graziano invece un duo siamo
entrambi i cantautori musicisti con tre
dischi all'attivo è un'intensa attività
live in praticamente in tutta europa
quindi compresa l'italia oltreoceano è
in espansione
una cosa che mi capita spesso dopo i
concerti e incontrare persone del
pubblico che dopo un elogio sentito e
commosso ci tengono a chiudere
le fasi con beh certo non sono un
esperto di musica oppure per quanto
possa valere la mia parola o addirittura
comunque io di musica non ne capisco
niente
che è un po come se io insomma
insomma volendo corteggiare una donna le
dicessi sei bellissimo non c'è senti mi
batte il cuore sei se meravigliosa ma
non ne capisco niente di donne e di
estetica femminile
quindi ecco qua chi ne capisce di musica
chi ha il diritto di parlarne e di dire
cosa emoziona
adesso comincerà un percorso e diciamo
affine speech darò una mia risposta
la musica
diciamo che accompagna l'uomo da sempre
in ogni latitudine ogni cultura
ogni grado evolutivo di ogni singola
civiltà la musica sotto forma di canti
ritmi e suoni viene viene utilizzata in
ogni occasione di festa di rito magico
religioso di funerale di aggregazione
durante il lavoro dopo il lavoro oppure
dico dice di schiavitù in condizioni di
prigionia
oppure che accomuna persone sotto una
stessa bandiera uno stesso ideale contro
lo stesso nemico lo stesso fragiello e
ho detto utilizzata perché in tutti
questi casi la musica è un mezzo non
accompagnamento e precisamente e il
tramite con l'emotività che le
circostanze richiede come se noi fossimo
ricoperti da tasti e ogni musica
specifica andasse a prendere alcuni di
questi tasti
ed è per questo che le messe di ogni
religione praticamente nascono come
preghiere collettive cantate in alcune
religioni come per esempio il sufismo la
musica viene talmente identificata come
discendenza divina da essere considerata
il tramite per l'incontro con dio
questa frase molto potente tra l'altro è
lo stesso concetto che me espresso un
chitarrista che io amavo moltissimo
nella mia formazione è che avuto la
fortuna di incontrare c'è di seguire in
un workshop con lui a roma quando avevo
18 anni
lui al chitarrista americano sera
svezzato da frank zappa e lui disse la
stessa cosa in maniera molto laica però
nello stesso concetto
nel frattempo passano i secoli e nei
nostri luoghi di culto si passa dai
canti gregoriani alle musichette di
chiesa per cui la catarsi si sposta
completamente in altri luoghi
quindi milioni di persone accorrono da
ogni parte del mondo per per eventi a
partire dagli anni sessanta che univano
anche anche per questioni sociali come
che ne so una protesta per la guerra in
vietnam
oppure per una raccolta fondi a sostegno
dell'africa o di tante altre cose ma
fondamentalmente si celebrava il sacro
fuoco del rock and roll
siamo nel frattempo nel pieno comuni e
consumismo per cui ahimè anche la musica
è un prodotto e fin qui ma col cambiare
delle del la vendibilità praticamente di
un prodotto il focus passa dalla musica
agli artisti dagli artisti all'immagine
degli artisti e dell'immagine degli
artisti a come fare perché si parli
dell'immagine degli artisti
nel frattempo le musiche più potenti
vengono mandate nelle serre per far
crescere meglio piante e frutti
il pare che lì che risultati siano
almeno di un 150 per cento di incremento
e nelle stalle nelle stalle per far fare
più il latte alle vacche
sappiate che in vetta alle classifiche
bovine di tutto il mondo pare ci sia
mozart
ok adesso è arrivato anche il turno
vostro avete aspettato un po ma c'è
anche tanto il turno vostra nel 3 nel
senso che faremo un esperimento di un
qualcosa insieme
che insomma nessun panico non è un
provino il mio portare in tour
non sarete giudicati per quello che
farete e non dobbiamo ottenere nessun
miracolo insomma so che non siete
cantanti professionisti ma un risultato
lo dobbiamo ottenere dobbiamo fare
qualcosa insieme e sentieri di fare
qualcosa tutti insieme di andare
comunque in risonanza sentire un po ma
questa di questo tipo di vibrazione io
inizierò cantando una nota con nessuno
della o perché voi di unire te a me
pensando una nota che stia bene con la
mia ognuno di voi singolarmente penserà
una nota che sta bene con la mia qui
qualcuno può anche fare la mia stessa
però sentitevi liberi fantasia e relax
quando finisce il fiato ispirate e
riprendete con la stessa nota la notte
questa
tutti insieme ad esso con giornate
andate avanti che avete fatto tutti la
mia nota
ok adesso a lanciatevi lanciatevi in
qualsiasi altra nota che secondo voi sta
bene con questa
i fermati non fermate
adesso trasformiamo questo suono sono di
aa
[Musica]
fermate le giornate adesso faccio 3 2 1
ora e poi cambiate nota in maniera
random e assolutamente istintiva in
grado di continuare a fare piega
cioè l'ultimo passaggio adesso sono
lettera i
[Musica]
il testo comunque la cosa è uscita la
cosa e uscite è già comunque l'atmosfera
di una diversa vocale cambia cambia
tutto quello insomma ok fine
adesso faremo qualcosa invece di più
strutturato perché sono qua anche in
veste di cantautore per cui cantano una
mia canzone di qualche anno fa che la
storia di un uomo che torna dopo tanti
anni dalla sua lei insomma da una lei
non la trova particolarmente accogliente
vi passerò una melodia che voi farete
dall'inizio alla fine della canzone se
no mi lasciate da solo insomma eppure va
bene però lo scopo è fare qualcosa
insieme che la mafia fa così
[Musica]
non ci credo neanche più
questa è la mia storia fai tu
la storia di un uomo che viene da
lontano in cerca di una donna chiederle
la mano
no
[Musica]
in cima alla città limite del bosco
accanto al fiume c'è una casa che
conosco busso quella porta alla soglia
del passato un'ora di insulti ancora non
sono entrato
[Musica]
ora non vale la pena più parlare
le cose si sistemano se uno vuole sì ma
come una preghiera
chiedo di farmi restare
qui
[Musica]
non puoi restare ho fatto a meno del tuo
amore novello
e ammesso rimasta ad aspettare ogni
giorno preso un pezzo
mio cuore l'ho superato
scocciato
pianta cresce
piena sull'orto l'albero
ma adesso è morto i fiori sono
ed i frutti insomma
non serve più a nessuno
qui che torri ma
[Musica]
ei frutti sono mar
prenderemo cari in quanto i fiori non ci
servono colore
a unire star
farò
ma questa è la
[Musica]
[Applauso]
al team parola state volta ci ha creduto
sì
ecco è sparito premi letto stralci
incanti summit
affogare
no
[Musica]
vado
ma quegli occhi li conosco tornerò tra
un anno
questo è il mio opposto molte grazie
molte grazie
gli faccio una conclusione breve del mio
discorso una conclusione del discorso
io credo che lo stato attuale delle cose
si sia perso un legame con una parte
fondamentale della musica e delle sue
potenzialità e questo diciamo ha portato
a contribuisce notevolmente allevi citt
di spiritualità del mondo occidentale di
oggi allontanato un po l'uomo dal dal
proprio sé per conoscere la propria
mappatura emotiva e quindi anche a una
conoscenza collettiva per cui il mio
appello di approfittare approfittare
della musica che comunque è qualcosa che
ci appartiene
sono ninfina infinita di linguaggi da
cui attingere e da cui prende se tutti i
regali che essa può fornirci oggi per
paradossalmente è più difficile andarsi
a trovare un certo tipo di musica
differente nel senso che il 90 per cento
delle cose trasmesse alla radio
televisioni e il playlist sul web
diciamo vanno a coprire quei tre tasti
che sono sempre gli stessi per cui noi
abbiamo tantissimi altri tasti che
l'uomo è capace di attivare con i suoni
e quindi questo è rispondendo alla
alla domanda iniziale la musica non è
per un élite di ascoltatori acculturate
può essere un percorso la musica esiste
perché è parte della vita dell'uomo e la
sua funzione sociale è fondamentale
prima ancora di essere un prodotto
culturale
vi lascio dicendovi che pensare alla
musica semplicemente come
intrattenimento e come avere shakespeare
dante e un nero e fai aprire bocca solo
per raccontarvi una barzelletta
niente grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]